لربما ورث الكسندر وانك الذكاء البشري من
والديه لكنه سخر الذكاء الاصطناعي في
مواهبه لجعله سببا في صناعه ثروه كبرى في
سن مبكره فبات اصغر ملياردير في اقل من
سته اعوام وجمع ثروه تقدر بنحو مليار
دولار قبل ان يتم عامه 25 انه الكسندر
وانج فما سر هذه الثروه ولد الكسندر وانج
عام
1997 ونشا في نيو مكسيكو حيث كان والداه
فيزيائيين عمل في مشروعات الاسلحه للجيش
وفي ظل مختبر لوس الاموس الوطني حيث تم
تطويل اول قنبله ذريه خلال الحرب العالميه
الثانيه خلال طفولته كان بارعا في
الرياضيات كما تعلم البرمجه عبر الانترنت
ذاتيا قبل ان يبدا مسيرته العمليه المبكره
حيث عمل كمبرمجا بدوام كامل في موقع
الكتروني للاسئله والاجوبه وهو في سن
السابعه عشر
بعد ان انهى مرحله الثانويه العامه حظي
الكسندر بقبول معهد ماسه
للتكنولوجيا لدراسه بكالوريوس العلوم
والرياضيات وعلوم الحاسوب حتى الان كانت
مسيره الكسندر طبيعيه لشاب من اسره
اكاديميه يسعى لاكمال تعليمه لكن الامر
تغير فجاه عندما قرر الانسحاب من الدراسه
في عام 2016 والبدء بمشروع من خلال شراء
استثمار لمجموعه واي كومبانيتر كان هذا
المشروع هو شركه البرمجيات سكاي التي
تعاون فيها مع زميله السابق في العمل
كانت فتنه الكسندر في ان كل صناعه تعتمد
على كميات هائله من البيانات ما يجعلها
تبحث عن متخصصين لمساعدتها على اطلاق
الاستفاده من البيانات وتعزيز اعمالها
باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي لكنه لم يكن
يعرف ان هذا العمل سيفتح له افاقا كبيره
كانت اعمال الشركه الجديده محطه اهتمام
العديد من الجهات بما في ذلك الجيش
الامريكي حيث تم توظيف امكانات شركه وانج
لتحليل صور الاقمار الصناعيه بشكل اسرع
بكثير من المحللين البشريين لتحديد مقدار
الضرر الذي تسببه القنابل الروسيه في
اوكرانيا خلال السنوات الاولى ابرمت شركه
ونج ثلاثه عقود تصل قيمتها الى 110 ملايين
دولار اعتمادا الاحتياجيات الحكومه
لمساعده القوات الجويه الامريكيه والجيش
على توظيف الذكاء الاصطناعي كذلك وجد وانج
ان المشروع مقبول لدى اكثر من 300 شركه
بما في ذلك جنرال موتورز وعملائها جي ام
كروس والفا بيت واوبر وبي ان جي وغيرها في
عام 2021 وبعد جوله تمويلا بقيمه 300
وخمسه وعشرين مليون دولار امريكي بلغت
قيمه الشركه سبعه مليارات
مليون دولار امريكي فيما قدرت حصه الكسندر
التي تعادل 15% من الشركه بنحو مليار
دولار امريكي ما جعله اصغر مليار عصامي في
العالم كذلك لدى الملياردير الصغير اليوم
مجموعه من الاعمال التجاريه الاخرى مثل
التسويق والاستثمار في سوق الاوراق
الماليه ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ورغم ان
انجازاته لقيت التقدير في العديد من
المنصات حول العالم الا ان اسرته لم تتقبل
حتى اليوم فكره تركه الدراسه
[موسيقى]